على خط اسلحه وتقنيات المواجهه العسكريه
المتواصله دون توقف بين روسيا واوكرانيا
يدخل سلاح المسيرات بشكل لافت موسكو مره
اخرى عرضه لهجوم بمسيره اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه احبطهم متهمة
تحديدا على منطقه موسكو بثلاث طائره مسيره
تم اسقاطها ليضيف حاكم منطقه موسكو ان
الجيش الروسي اعترض طائرتين كانت تقتربان
بالمستودعات عسكريه في المنطقه هذا في
الداخل الروسي اما في دنيا فقد سجلت هجمه
للقوات الاوكرانيه بمسيارات استهدفت مبنى
سكنيا ومنطقتين اخريين وفق سلطات دانياسكا
المواليه لروسيا اللجوء الى المسيرات ياتي
بينما يستمر هجوم المضاد الذي تشونه
اوكرانيا لاسيما في الجبهه الجنوبيه من
البلاد وسط حديثها عن تقدم عسكري باتجاه
جنوبا من محور زابولوجيا
لكن حسم المعركه على الارض بدا رهنا ايضا
بتحقيق تقدم بريم فعلى امتداده شبهات
لا يبدو ذلك تحقق للاوكرانيين بالنظر
لاحتزام المعارك على غرار ما حدث في بخموت
موقع رضوان العسكري الروسي قال ان القتال
الاعنف مستمر في منطقه اوريخوفا في اتجاه
زابولوجيا واشار الموقع الى ان مظليين
اوكرانيين حاولوا اختراق الدفاعات الروسيه
في الغابات المحيطه بالمنطقه دون جدوى ولم
تنقطع مطالب كياف بالحصول على الصواريخ
بعيده المدى تمكنها من احداث اختراق في
الجبهات رغم ما حصلت عليه حتى الان من
منظومه هايمارس الامريكيه او صواريخ ستارب
شادو البريطانيه وهو ما اثار قلق وزير
الدفاع الروسي وجعل اي تقدم اوكراني
رهنا بالحصول على مزيد من الاسلحه الغربيه
ويبدو غياب ما يكفي من الطائره المقاتله
لتغطيه على اي تقدم عامل حسم اخر لم يتوفر
ضمن ادوات المعركه التي يمكنها مرافقته
هجوم كييف المضاد فلاديمير بوتين قال ان
تعزيز قدره الجيش اولويه بينما تحدث وزير
دفاعه عن ان الجيش الروسي وفي ظروف صعبه
يفعل ما بوسعه ويبذل كل ما لديه لتعزيز
سياده وامن البلاد اما تكثيف كييف استخدام
المسيرات فبدا وفق محللين عسكريين نابعا
من التكلفه الرمزيه لهذا السلاح وقدرته
على احداث ضجيج اعلامي دون التسبب في
الوقت نفسه باحداث تدمير كبير للمواقع
التي يستهدفها ولا تبدو المسيرات وفقهم
بديلا من سلاح الصواريخ حيث كشف رد فعل
الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه على هجوم الطائره
المسيره على موسكو ان هذا النظام يعمل
بشكل فعال وقادر على التعرف على الاهداف
العسكريه للعدو وتدميرها لكن التحدي الذي
بقي يثير تساؤلات يتعلق بمصدر الهجمات
خصوصا ان هجمات الكرملين تبدو انها انطلقت
من مكان يبعد كيلومترات فقط عنه مرجح
فرضيه الهجوم من الداخل وهنا معركه اخرى
قد تجد موسكو نفسها في مواجهتها